- We're gonna put snail
shit on our face, guys.
- It's okay.
Whatever it takes to get
beautiful skin, I'll do it.
(bright music)
- It's overwhelming how
many products there are.
- Yeah.
- I've heard of some snail products
where you use the slime of the snail
to put on your face,
and it's supposed to
make your skin smoother
or something like that.
- Is that what we're trying today?
- [Interviewer] Yes.
- Oh, is it actually?
(record scratch) Oh no.
- I love new skincare stuff.
- I do too at... Oo, snail.
- Oh.
- Snail slime.
- Snail slime?
- Alright, alright.
- How do you collect
this much snail slime? (guy laughs)
Like, how many snails
did you have to follow?
- It is what I pictured, that
it was just like a little--
- Milking a snail?
- Yeah.
- If I can recall correctly,
playing with snails as a young child,
it will be slimy
and cold.
- I just picture those,
like, cartoon snails
with that trail of,
like, shit behind them.
You know what I mean?
And then it's like, wipe it
up, and put it on your face.
That's what they're telling you to do.
- Pretty much.
- I'm nervous about the smell.
- Okay, I'll be very brave.
- Alright.
It's clear.
It looks like a hand
sanitizer a little bit.
- It's very thick.
- You know in, um, Cruel Intentions--
- Nope, nope.
- When (laughs)
come on.
The scene where they're making out,
and then there's that spit
- Yeah, yeah.
- This is what this is like.
- Ew, it's like it's snot.
- That's disgusting.
It, like, doesn't break.
Look at that.
- It's like--
- Legit like mucus.
- Beautiful.
- It's not as slimy as
I thought it would be.
- Snails don't smell so bad.
- For under eye area, tap
as if playing the piano
to make skin absorb its acids.
This is the most Asian instructions
I've ever read in my life.
My mom wrote this.
- Tap as like you're playing the piano.
Oh, I didn't do that.
(ragtime piano music)
- I haven't played the piano
since like the third grade.
Is this right?
- I like the feel. Do you like the feel?
(record scratch)
- Oh, I was busy--
- Playing the piano?
- Playing the piano on my face.
- Playing the keys?
- I feel like it gives
a nice little shine.
I like it.
But now it kinda feels like
my skin's getting tight.
Whoa.
- Oh, now that you said that,
I think I feel it.
- It makes your skin kinda shiny.
- I look dewy as fuck.
- And that's always good.
- Yeah.
- Let me see.
It looks, oh yeah,
it looks good.
- It looks, like, dewy.
- The moister it is, the
fewer wrinkles I'm gonna get.
- That's like the grossest sentence
that's ever come out of anybody's mouth.
- It doesn't feel heavy
because I hate, like, heavy skincare.
It feels, like, really nice and light.
- I really like the way this feels.
I'm getting that fresh air
scent under my eyes right now.
It's feeling really good.
- If someone sat me down and was like,
"Listen, if you put 96 snails on your face
"every day for, like,
the rest of your life
"you won't age," I'd probably do it
cause I would do anything.
- Probably? Damn, I
would definitely do it.
- I would totally use it again.
It's very light.
I feel like it's super
good for summer too.
- Hey man, my friend used
placenta on her face.
There was a placenta cream,
so, like, I don't think
this is any worse, yeah.
- Snail slime's not that bad.
Don't judge a book by its cover.
And don't judge a snail
by its shell, alright?
- What if another animal
came and took our snot--
- And then put it on their skin?
- And they were like,
"It makes me beautiful."
- Yeah, we probably
wouldn't appreciate that.
- I mean, I guess if we could monetize it.